well hello and welcome to stem Business
School and beyond
and my name is Allison Davis and I'm
with the MBA admissions office our focus
today is on how you can combine your
background in stem with a business
education with me are two alumni and
current students share why they chose to
pursue an MBA and how they are combining
their experiences at Stanford with their
passion for stem our purpose today is
not to describe the MBA program in depth
or to explain the admissions process
this information is available on our
website and through admissions events
that you can attend on or off campus we
have 45 minutes together today and we're
going to focus entirely on your question
so let's start by having each of our
panelists introduce yourselves and tell
us a little bit about what you did
before Business School and what you're
doing now so let's start with you Bryce
sure so my name is Bryce Mara dick
I'm the MBA class of 2014
here's the GSB and before business
school I came here straight out of a PhD
in material science and engineering at
Northwestern in Chicago my research
involved trying to design new materials
atom-by-atom on the computer so pretty
pretty theoretical stuff and I decided
to come to the come to the GSB to see
how I could combine come on business
with my interest in science and more
business thinking besides Thank You
Bryce and Maura I'm Maura I'm also in
the class of 2014 with Bryce before the
GSB I have a bachelor's in electrical
and computer engineering from Cornell
and a master's and in management as
named to the software developer then is
management called and then doing product
for tech startup in San Francisco so for
me I knew that
start a business and I saw that the
background I had gave me all the
technical expertise but not the business
expertise to really start a successful
business on my own so I saw that this
was the right time to come to business
call and kind of enhance that as this is
not alright and Savannah hi everyone my
name is Savannah McCoy and I am an alum
of the class of 2013 before business
school I got a bachelor's degree in
mechanical engineering from Cornell
similar samatha and I worked for four
years at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
which is a NASA facility that focuses
primarily on planetary exploration and I
was a mechanical engineer there I had a
highly technical role so did everything
from design test analysis and ultimately
ended up leaving a team of engineers on
the test effort for the curiosity Mars
rover which is really on Mars and landed
last summer so that's a little bit about
my pre-mba experience in terms of why I
decided to pursue an MBA this story is
somewhat similar do my peers on the
panel here in that I had the technical
expertise and I really wanted to build
out some of the kind of business
functional experience as well as I'm
just a managerial mindset all right
first question that came from someone
who had signed up in advance during your
experience in in the STEM fields that
you came from was there any particular
situation or experience that fueled your
desire to pursue an MBA and price again
let's start with
was there any particular situation that
really made it clear to you gee I want
to get my MBA yeah absolutely I'm
actually glad can't me to answer this
one because I was eager to do it so when
I saw you know in the materials
Department in northwestern and just the
university as a whole a lot of great
science and engineering research
happening and and the fair number of the
professor's there want to start
companies they're trying to figure out
ways to bring their lab bench
innovations to the market but oftentimes
when they tried to do that they would
they were run into what I guess what I
would call kind of mundane business
barriers or bottlenecks that would
really prevent them from fulfilling that
dream and and these were incredibly
brilliant technically savvy people and I
wanted to have that that technical side
but also have the business acumen and
the knowledge to to make that leap from
from basic science to stuff that impacts
people's everyday lives okay how about
you mana I think for me my I realized I
need an MBA when I worked for a tech
startup in SF called Yolo there was you
know a great product and I felt that we
were we had a better product and most of
our competitors but we weren't made a
lot of business mistakes we didn't
really think a business plan think about
the corn users the right way and being
there and working in the startup I
really care about this think that it was
in a way failing I realized that if I
started my own company I wouldn't want
to go to those mistakes so I came in
into the GSB knowing very clearly these
things I didn't know and I was very
excited to look to learn them so alright
and Savannah yeah so my my trajectory
was similar but a little bit different
so coming out of Cornell with a
technical degree I can say that I at the
time he definitely did not intend to get
an MBA I didn't have a very clear vision
of what the next kind of five to ten
years looks like but getting an MBA
wasn't something that was been kind of
my near term goals
initially out of graduation and it was
really motivated by I don't think there
was one defining experience but just
kind of the experience of the whole in
working at an environment that is so
highly technical and is so highly
science driven and necessarily so being
that it's kind of NASA and doing things
for the first time but I started to see
kind of the business and management a
deficiency in myself primarily but also
in some of my peers and some of my
superiors and I just kind of had a
revaluation of what I wanted and where I
was going and I thought the best way to
kind of bolster the skill set that I
thought I was missing was by going back
to school and ultimately getting an MBA
thank you
and I'm going to come back to madness I
think you're back on the line are you
Magnus yep
can you hear me yes and I'm gonna have
you first introduce yourself Magnus and
say a little bit about what you were
doing before business school and what
you were what you're doing now okay so
everyone I had some technical
difficulties so my name is Magnus
Johansen I grew up in Sweden and I have
a master's in pharmacology and then I
got a PhD of cell biology and followed
up by doing a postdoc at the used
yourself as a cancer researcher so I
came to my MBA program without the any
business experience whatsoever and I
love that GSB
during my time there I worked for pharma
company and currently I'm managing a
cancer business for a medical device
company and I graduated in 2012 septum I
graduated last year and then I guess was
there any particular experience or
situation
that really fueled your desire for an
MBA yeah definitely so is for me when I
started out as a scientist my the reason
why I wanted to be in research was that
I wanted to help people so I was a
cancer researcher trying to find new new
ways of treating cancer and you
ironically enough a colleague of mine
managed to make a big discovery and then
we realized that we didn't know how to
commercialize it so yeah I just realized
that having a deep knowledge in one
field isn't enough if you don't know how
to actually bring it to market even you
won't end up benefiting patients so that
was kind of a triggering moment for me
when I decided I needed to go back to
school
Randall's my career with an MBA
wonderful and how would each of you say
that your stem background helped prepare
you for Business School let's start with
you modest but I think looking at the
courses
it was definitely easier for me to go
through the more quantitative courses so
though I had no previous experience with
things like accounting or you know even
beta modeling and so forth I found it
easier to go to those courses then the
other courses that came harder to me
like the communication courses and the
courses on only one entrepreneurship and
leadership but I found those although
those who came harder to me I found the
most battery in those and ultimately I
think it really helped me while I was a
business school to kind of pursue my
goal of starting a company so I thought
that that was really right yeah I mean
so to touch on something besides the
courses I agree with what mater just
said but to me I think if you know
business done done well or done right is
actually very quantitative and I found
since I've been here there's an
expectation that good managers are very
good with numbers and you'll be asked
questions whether you're starting your
own
or leading people in a different
business you know what are your critical
metrics how are you tracking them how
are you driving them what are the knobs
you turn for success and it almost
always comes back to number then if
you're just making you know gut calls
and you can't back them up with data you
know I think that's not not a good way
to lead so you know I found that that
that's the expectation around here is
that you you are savvy with numbers and
so the stem background fits in naturally
with that okay yeah so I definitely
agree with a different with the previous
comments something that I've really
appreciated is that when you already
have a deep good education on your stem
camp you're already specialized and this
frees you up during your MBA so you can
go really wide and take a catalyst
you're really interested in a lot of my
classmates we're trying to get that
specialization through the MBA so for
example are going to eat and finance or
going deep in the different areas like
entrepreneurship but I already felt that
I had a deep enough knowledge in biology
so I didn't have that problem and
savanna and so I definitely agree with
with what that other panelists have said
in terms of kind of the ease with which
some of the quantitative coursework
comes to someone who has a stem
background or is comfortable with like
the math and sciences one counterpoint I
would say though is at least for me and
I think this is probably definitely kind
of an individual reflection or maybe
personality specific but the style of
business school was very different for
me kind of coming from an engineering
background and part of that is the
teaching method the case method a lot of
participation points and you chase
discussions and that was kind of a stark
contrast from my engineering background
where your graded primarily on problem
sets and and not necessarily on
these group aspects so that said it was
a challenge for me coming from them but
at the same time I see that as one of my
greatest growths and kind of take away
from the two years at Business School
and so for me that provided a very
strong incentive to make the decision to
get an MBA and reflecting back is one of
the more valuable things that I've taken
away right someone asks we hear about
people like Marissa Mayer and Mark
Zuckerberg and a multitude of others who
were engineers never went to business
school and have been extremely
successful on the business side of
alekan Valley what do you think an
engineer could learn or gain in Business
School that he or she could not
accomplish by just continuing to work in
their current company's price yeah I
think so that's actually that's a great
question it's one that that I've been
asked to is you know why not just go
work why not go into consulting or
something kind of learn MBA type skills
on the fly I would go back to actually
what would Magnus said which is that for
me anyway Business School was a really
efficient way to go really broad in a
lot of different areas of business and
and understand different industries
different functions you know different
types of products and services so you
know at least for me it was the right
choice in terms of being able to go
broad go general and rather than you
know if I had ended up in a job it would
have been a highly specialized
scientific job most likely and I didn't
want to go deeper down that rabbit hole
I wanted to you know pull back a little
bit and get a broader survey of what I
could do I kind of want to echo what
Bryce just said I think similarly I
actually did the year and management
consulting and I didn't feel that I got
the right business experience I worked
with some really big companies and I
learned a lot but I learned a lot more
about client engagement and business at
the very large scale and for me I was
looking to learn about how to run a
business a smaller scale and for that
you need
broad range of business experience and I
stink with this general management
program Stanford really puts an emphasis
on that so in the first year we have to
take courses it's all the different
types all the different sides of
business and while in the second year
you take electives and you can focus on
what you want to do in this the first
year make sure that you have a really
broad understanding of all the different
business size of business Magnus would
you like to comment yeah I'm not an
engineer but yeah I think it's I would
say that you're learning the develop of
getting MBA is that you're learning
everything that you're traditionally
pretty bad at at least personally as a
scientist it was a really steep learning
curve and I think if you're trying to
learn the same same things on the job
especially for me since it was very far
from my comfort zone a lot of these
things I was learning it will taking a
tremendous amount of time to get
exposure to all those field so it's a
great way of in two years to get
exposure to a lot of different fields
like rifles mentioning and Savannah any
any comments from you with a your Emmy
background and I mean I guess I would
just say that those examples that are
highly anecdotal and and every one he
kind of has a different path and each
individual has to make a decision that's
right for them and I think you can find
examples that would be exceptions to
pretty much any role so I guess that's
all I have all right someone asks for
those of you with an engineering
background how is it working with your
peers as a student here is it easier to
work with you know other other engineer
years who have similar backgrounds or
other stem backgrounds versus of the
other peers you may have that don't have
those those backgrounds and want to kick
it off Bryce sure yeah so I can actually
give an example so it's been it's
actually great I've loved you know being
one of the scientists here I mean it's
you know you're a small percentage of
class that people tend to remember who
who the science scientists engineers are
and people the GSB since this is a great
community are very open to you know
learning about others expertise and
trying to connect that to what they're
doing so as an example you know I've
like I said I have a materials
background and a friend of mine here
from my section is was doing a project
in Rwanda where they were trying to
develop extremely low-cost waterproof
flooring for Rwandan homes and she and I
sat down and had a conversation over
coffee about how from a materials
perspective how would you hit the
properties that they wanted in terms of
waterproof strong enough durable enough
and yet incredibly cheap I mean it had
to be the point where you know you're
not importing raw materials like
plastics that are made in other
countries you can't afford that there so
it was it was a chance for me to apply
my expertise and materials to a totally
different situation but you know she
knew that I had materials back on so she
you know tapping for that I think it's
definitely what especially the beginning
is easier to be in teams with people who
have similar backgrounds because you can
communicate with them better but I have
really kind of gone out of my way and
spot friends and teammates they were
different because I think I learned a
lot more from working with people that
come from very diverse backgrounds from
finance or nonprofits these are people
that are incredible and working with
them I learned a different way of
working in the complain of approaching a
problem and similar to Bryce's
experiences I was able to bring my
expertise and help people launch their
blogs or build a website with my you
know my software development experience
can you say a little bit more about how
oh you said you learned to work
differently from working with people who
are so different from you can you give
any examples of what what it was that
you learned I think I'm trying to think
of an example so for example in the
first year at Stanford you in first
quarter you thought the course for
leadership where you are together with
your squad of six people in a room and
you guys go through simulations and it
was very interesting seeing how people
who came from a finance or a much
heavier consulting background look the
things in the way they approach a
problem versus me where I try to only
look at numbers they looked at different
things in different ways that you know
our solution was impacting the clients
and I thought it was pretty interesting
and initially it actually caused
conflict because we had such an amazing
at the problem but as we moved along we
and and we became a team we'll learn we
started to learn from each other and
kind of bring on our different points of
view into the problem and I imagine that
part of the learning too is just
managing that conflict and yeah when
identification that's what the course is
all about managing and I think they did
that on purpose they put their average
people in that group of six like we came
from very different backgrounds
different countries and yeah I was the
suit interesting it was an amazing
experience and I'm like very close with
all of them and I one of my co-founders
one of people in that group film
Savannah how about for you what was it
like working with people who had a
non-stem background um so I would echo a
lot of what Mata said if you could
initially particularly kind of given my
my background in a very technical
organization I was much more comfortable
just kind of communicating and
interacting with engineering and people
with science and math backgrounds but
ultimately the greatest teams are are
composed of a diverse set of individuals
and each kind of background and
experience that a person brings to a
team or to a group shades the
perspective that they have on a
particular problem and the some of those
parts is so much greater than any
individual or any kind of subset or
specialty within that team so I think it
just makes for so much more richness in
a team environment and problem-solving
etc seeing the different tasks that
people have to to a solution thank you
in terms of your technical skills where
any of you concerned about maintaining
your technical skills while you were in
school and even you know going off into
a different kind of career week are you
concerned about that and how how did you
go about maintaining your technical
skills and Magnus I'll I'll go to you
first yeah I I think ultimate is a yes
you're going to lose some of the
technical skills I think it's inevitable
but it's also your shift in the focus so
for me from I went from being very much
of a specialist and now in my current
role I'm much more a generalist and no
one is asking me questions we have other
people in organization who are supposed
to be a specialist but the delicate I
have is that I can talk to the
researchers to the engineers and I can
also bring that message to the marketing
team so I would say that my
understanding has did the way I try to
understand my field has definitely
changed and in the needs have changed it
but other than that I try to keep up to
speed with keep in contact with my other
all the colleagues go to scientific
meetings and so on
so on so you have to be a bit more
footwork and keep up the speed okay and
Savannah how about for you any concern
about losing your technical skills while
you were in business school um honestly
not really yeah that wasn't something
that I was really that concerned about
but at the same time I was coming from a
background albeit highly technical I
didn't have a PhD so I hadn't gone to
quite the extent of specialization and I
think it's like anything it's you just
have to kind of continue to push
yourself and and and learn and if you're
not getting kind of that exercise in one
place you just have to find it somewhere
else so it wasn't something that I
worried about or really struggled with
model you wanted to comment yes I think
it's really a personal choice I think
the Stanford MBA is flexible enough that
if you want to continue to enhance your
technical skills you can so one of my
co-founders took for computer science
courses in the first year and advanced
the pure science courses so for him
while he was learning business she was
also enhancing his technical skills I
learned how to code in Python for
example I had never done before because
that was something I was interested in
and at the same time getting a great
business education and I think so I
think if you want to you can definitely
go deeper into either your your field or
a different field because you are
Stanford and you can take courses in
other in other departments and I think
it's a great idea to take courses on
Department so again the our personal
choice right yeah so I would echo that
too because um I ended up starting a
company that's developing software for
material scientists with another GSB or
who has a materials background and so
we're going to technical conferences
I've still been writing publications
while I've been here I was at Stanford
materials undergrad so I've stayed in
really close touch with all my former
professors and I you know swing by their
offices we talk shop so you can like
model
that you can you can keep those skills
as sharp as you want if that fits with
your goal or if your goals are to be
more of a generalist there's other paths
you can take so I think it's totally
flexible and it's kind of what you want
to do and as not to mention you're
you're on the campus of Stanford
University with six other you know
world-class schools so it's very common
for our students to take you know
classes and engineering or responses or
medical school and you can actually take
up to 12 units and have those captured
your MBA and it the program is flexible
enough that you can very easily pursue a
second degree and so that's quite
popular among our students about one in
six they're doing a second degrees of
idea master's in computer science or law
degree
would have whatever interests them here
on campus let's talk a little bit about
innovation and are there any lessons
learned during Business School that have
changed the way you look at innovation
within your chosen field who would like
to start right yeah I mean I think yes
especially coming from sort of a an
academic or scientific background where
there's a lot of talk about ideas and
having great ideas and you know
brilliant strokes of insight and stuff
and then you know when I you know we
talked earlier in the call about how to
take you know fundamental innovations
and translate them in the marketplace
which i think is really important
innovation and a lot of that is can you
execute and get the job done and ship
something and I think that's something
that you that you learn about a lot in
Business School and that's something
that I think was missing in at least in
my sort of academic training where it
was you know have a great idea and that
sort of you know you've proven your
point but now it's you have to have a
great idea and get into a customers
hands that's a really a very different
thing I think I also used to look at
innovation from a technical point of
view so innovation had to
that you do something better or you do
something no one else has done before I
think now I look at innovation more as
finding a product market fit and finding
I need that I can find a way to solve
and maybe the way you solve it it's not
that different than a lot of people have
that have done it but it's more like
maybe you think something that someone
else has done and you apply to different
markets and that can be Novation or
innovation can be a different way of
doing a business model which is
something I'm trying with my business
right now so I think yeah I stopped
looking at it just as a technical
innovation and more of your product
innovation how about you Magnus yeah I
definitely agree with Bruce another I
would say another thing that they
realized in b-school is that innovation
is not just about the best technical
solution maybe the best
sometimes the best solution is not the
one that the most elegant one the most
precise one but the one that can
actually be adopted and often something
that is very simple and cheap could be a
much better solution or something that's
very elegant and very complicated yeah
so the only thing I would add is that I
think at least for me when I was working
in a kind of a technical capacity I
almost started to get a little bit of
tunnel vision and focus so much on the
task at hand and the tasks that my team
was working on that I neglected kind of
innovation that can potentially come
outside from out from outside of your
field and I think that one thing that
the GSB is really great at is giving
exposure to a lot of different
industries and key helping students see
how innovations can kind of translate
across industries or inspire better more
elegant solutions of Magnus said maybe
in a different capacity
and Savannah how have you leveraged your
business degree to launch your career or
accelerate your career in since you are
still in a stem field yeah so I mean my
MBA definitely enabled me to do what I'm
doing now so I went into Stanford
wanting to round out my skill set but
also with this desire to pursue
entrepreneurship and have enough kind of
business skills as well as enough
confidence even to go down that path and
I'm working now at a biotech startup
that's very early stage we have a
product that's kind of going through FDA
approval and I'm responsible for the
business function so marketing
operations and coordinating everything
even from a project management
perspective with the engineers and the
science so I really have that
cross-functional experience that I was
looking for and I think it was very much
enabled by both my engineering
background but also the skills that I
built at Stanford and Bryson Mata you've
both have mentioned launching businesses
can you isolate what what is it that you
think you are bringing to those
businesses that you wouldn't have
otherwise if you if you hadn't been
getting the MBA it's interesting because
I think where all of the three
co-founders of my business are engineers
who are sign your business I think it's
interesting that bringing that those two
skills together it allows us to each
focus on doing something that's very
technical but at the same time make
business decisions together and make
really sound business decision
and being able to run numbers and do
things in a very quantifiable and
profitable way which is something that
never happened in my own startup so I
think I think that it's really great and
we see a lot of value from having both
those backgrounds for both business
degree and the technical background
beforehand how about you Brian
I mean thinking about where I was the
end of my PhD and and I was always
somebody who had kind of had an
entrepreneurial bent or the inclination
I would have had no idea where to even
start
in terms of forming and running a
business and and some of that's really
mundane day-to-day stuff and some of
that longer term strategy and vision and
to me you know Business School or the
NBA has been about how do you Marshall
couple and resources behind pursuing a
really important goal and that's
something that I just doesn't academic I
had no idea frankly your idea how to do
that and and now that I've been you know
that I'm kind of looking at the end of
my time of the Jesus yeah I can't
pinpoint any one class or any one person
I met but just kind of steeping in this
for as long as I have it's changed that
situation dramatically in terms of the
level sophistication and it comes
through and you know we're talking to
investors there was a time when I would
have viewed them what I would have been
I guess intimidated by that and now it's
very much a pure conversation or even
that they're maybe even talking up to me
in some cases
and sometimes I have to take a step back
and say wow that never ever would have
happened before I went to GSB great
someone is asking about classes of the
d.school
so we have a design school here at
Stanford that we do a lot of
collaboration with in fact one of our
professors of Jim patell was the
co-founder of the D school and that's a
great resource for our graduate students
so if any of you took classes at the
d.school can you talk a little bit about
what that was like and how that enhanced
your MBA education sure so I took a
design school class School Lunch pads
that's taught by
one of the design and product guys Mary
and Michael Dearing which is of BC here
in the valley and it was probably one of
the most amazing experiences my team
formed in that class and we didn't stick
with the idea in that class and because
we learned through it that although we
launched it we realized that that was
maybe not the right fit for us but we
became a team and we learned we
incorporated the company we learn how to
work together and we really learn how to
bring a product to life which was
amazing because we then spent the next
two months over Amer and we use
everything we learned in that class
blast everything we had learning all the
business school classes and took an idea
from just an idea to being you know a
large company with revenues at the end
of summer so it was great not just
because of the people teaching it but it
was a very different experience and some
of the other business school classes and
we were the other teams were not just
cool they were from all this other
fields so we learned a lot from the
peers in that class with frequency
anyone else takes classes at the
d.school that would like to add anything
else yeah it just - I took it by design
innovation the fast when you're
basically starting a medical device
startup and I it was feel incredible and
especially I think anyone with a stem
background would benefit from learning
design thinking because as an engineer
as a scientist they're really good at
using the same scientific method
from breaking down a problem and Design
Thinking is basically the opposite you
look at the customer you look at em user
try to learn as much as possible about
how they use the product how to
emphasize the rhythm and to just
understand how they are thinking so you
learn - very good complementary methods
when solving a problem and we get up out
in the real world it's really useful to
have those two point of views
thank you we're coming up on 45 minutes
we have a few minutes left so I'm going
to ask each of you if do you just have
any last you know words of wisdom or
pearls again particularly for our skin
Maude Ian's as they're thinking of if an
MBA is worthwhile for them so any advice
about anything I'll start with you Bryce
yeah so I would go back to the point
that was that was made before about you
know Mark Zuckerberg didn't need an MBA
you know Bill Gates the name need a
college degree right I mean what I guess
I would just urge everyone to to worry
about your own situation and think you
know where am I what's right for me you
know as you as you think about you know
whether the GSB is a good fit only you
can make that decision and there's going
to be example of encounter examples for
every possible contingency and plan you
could pursue and it's really easy to get
bogged down in that so my advice would
just be really focused on your own
situation and what feels right for you
and that's right because I definitely a
lot of people question my decision to
come to business school but I'm really
glad I did it
and I'm going to ask you to do the same
question but if any of you also wants to
comment on timing how did you know when
the right time was - to get the NBA I
think for me I'm on the older size of my
class and I was very worried coming in
that maybe I shouldn't have done I
shouldn't do an MBA and I really
struggled with this decision but I
should just try to start a company on my
own or or come to an MBA and I got most
of the advice I got was not to do an MBA
but looking back I really think it was
like probably one of the best decisions
of my life to come and do it I think
what the things I learned and they have
enabled me to really really build a
successful business and learn how to
build a successful
and I feel that I would think that with
me wherever I go
no matter what happens and also I want
to urge people who have probably maybe
more experience than others to not like
be intimidated by that and think again
it's bright sad is this the right time
for you I don't think there's really any
age I mean we we have people here from
in my class from 0 to 16 years of
experience and I think everyone has
found the MPA is very valuable and for
me I think that this time when I knew I
needed to come and do an MBA was when I
found problems I couldn't solve without
an MBA and so problems in a company that
I had no idea how to fix and a lot of
them were like softer skill problems
like how do you retain people how do you
keep them engaged I I just I could see
that all these things are going wrong
and I would have not known how to do
those things right if I just went and
tried to start a company while now I
feel I learned so much and I'm so much
better Magnus any any last thoughts yeah
well what I like about the MBA is it's
very very very different from Graduate
Studies and any other field especially
STEM fields I believe you learn anything
that you as I do have learned during my
PhD when I got into my MBA I didn't know
the difference between economics and
finance I was completely business naive
and I learned so much the it was really
interesting so as I said figure out if
it's a good fit for you and if this is
the right time and if so go for it thank
you
Savannah you have the last word all
right well my three kind of peers here
on the panel made it easy for me because
I think they summed it up really nicely
it really is an individual decision and
for all of us here I think it was the
right decision and a transformative
experience but I guess I would just
encourage everyone who's listening today
to just reflect on
where they are enables their technical
careers anywhere they see that going in
the future and just be very intentional
about kind of the schools that you're
looking at and the decisions they make
be it to go to business school or to
Brisco another path I don't think you
can go wrong but just be intentional and
make those decisions with purpose and
have kind of that end goal in sight
thank you if you have further questions
you can contact our office and there is
on our website there's a place where you
can ask a question and we're going to
show you that just in it so you can ask
a question and you can also call us
we're open every day from 8:00 to 4:00
and our phone number is on the website
and we do a pretty good job of getting
back to people quickly the other thing I
would encourage you to do is to fill out
the stay in touch form which is on our
website and the reason you'd want to do
this is we would like to keep you posted
on our upcoming travel schedule for the
information sessions I mentioned that we
do all over the world and other relevant
news like our new computer science MBA
joint degree which which launched this
year and the MS Electrical Engineering
MBA joint degree which we expect to
launch next fall so thank you very much
to our panelists for taking the time to
speak with us and thank you all for
attending good night